hi here's a question for the whiz kids
among you is this system here
controllable at a point X E with
asymptotic control UE I'll give you ten
seconds okay ten seconds are over so to
solve this it's actually pretty easy all
you need to do is first differentiate
the system with respect to its internal
variables which are the x's to obtain
the Jacobian a second step differentiate
the system with respect to its control
variables which are the u variables to
obtain the matrix B look this is a zero
like this is not hard then evaluate a
and B at the point that you want and the
control point that you want pretty easy
calculate the controllability matrix
come on that's nothing another zero and
at the end you calculate the rank of the
controllability matrix now if the if n
minus D is zero this system is
controllable and optionally if you want
if you feel like it you can output the
control feedback matrix as an equation 3
which gives you this here then what's
equation 3 equation 3 is super duper
simple it's just this little sort of
integral thing inverse matrix trace
transposed exponential function outer
product thing come on what's the matter
with you ok so if you found you can't do
this just on the spot then you are in
the same category as most people but
interestingly apparently according to
this paper a deep learning system can so
today we're going to look at deep
differential system stability learning
advanced computations from examples by
phosphor shot on a movie hiya
and giome lamp of facebook AI research
and equal to papa high tech and rockers
Rutgers University so at this in this
paper these authors basically propose
that you can learn these complex
mathematics with a model that has no
clue
about mathematics in fact it is a
language model and it can output the
solutions for example whether or not a
system is controllable which are sort of
binary solutions but it can also output
actual solutions as in numbers or as in
the matrices that you would need to
obtain from these problems so that's
pretty cool and it is built upon this
other paper called I think some deep
learning for symbolic mathematics or
something I have made a video on it if
you search for it and I'll also link it
in in the description and you can go
check that out because that's sort of
the basis so in this previous paper I
think it was from partially the same
authors they have investigated language
models into integrating functions so you
have some sort of function you're trying
to find the integral and they've tried
to do that now they go a lot further so
they look at these D at these
differential systems which are
characterized by these differential
equations so if you've never seen
differential equations it's basically an
equation where the derivation of some
variable is characterized by the
variable itself so the the the gradient
if you will or the Jacobian the
derivation according to some input
variable here it's most often it's time
and physical systems is a function of
that variable itself and partially also
of other variables so you can have
systems of differential equations that
all depend on each other and there are a
number of questions about these systems
these are very relevant in like physics
or engineering control theory and so on
so they investigate different problems
that you can solve with these they
investigate specifically problems where
we already know the solutions but the
solutions require very complex
mathematical manipulation such as as
you've seen calculate the integral of
something
take the trace calculate the rank invert
some matrix so all of these mathematical
steps are required to solve these
problems if we were to teach them to
math students or engineering students
and this paper basically says if we just
input the problem into a big language
model and and ask it to output the
solution it can do it so basically can
learn to do all of these things so
that's pretty pretty surprising because
you don't program it to do any math so
the first problem they look at is this
local stability problem so in I don't I
don't really want to go into into much
of the actual mathematical problems but
we'll look at the first one to just give
you an idea of what these sort of
problems are so XT is an if X is an
equilibrium point it means that all
solutions if all solutions converge to
XE when their initial positions are
close enough the equilibrium point is
said to be locally stable ok
this problem is well-known if F is
differentiable in XE and answer is
provided by the spectral mapping theorem
so in that case you'd have a system
maybe we can draw one where you try to
find local points of stability so this
point here would be maybe a local point
of stability if you consider this as
sort of an optimization landscape
because if you go from here if you go a
little bit away from it you're always
sort of pushed back if this if this is a
if the system is gravity sort of so if
these differential equations did sort of
describe that the the height here is the
force which with which you're pulled
down then this thing here would be a
local point of stability the question is
if I give you a system that's described
by these differential equations can you
tell me whether or not it is stable at
some point
okay and there is a spectral mapping
theorem which says if you have the
Jacobian matrix of F at this point the
matrix of its partial derivatives
relative to its variable and if you take
lambda to be the largest real part of
its complex eigenvalues if lambda is
positive then this is an unstable
equilibrium if lambda is negative then
it's a locally stable equilibrium so an
unstable equilibrium likewise would be
the point here on top which means that
if you're exactly at the point then you
stay there but as soon as you're a
little bit off you drift away from it
that would be an unstable equilibrium
okay so there are complex steps involved
in deriving this solution and they list
them out here just to show you how
complex this is this is not meant to
teach you you don't have to like
understand or be able to apply this this
is simply meant to tell you how
complicated it is to arrive at a
solution so first you need to
differentiate each function with respect
to each variable and obtain the formal
Jacobian so they do this here for this
example system which is this system
right here this is a system of two
equations at two differential equations
in two variables okay so if you derive
the Jacobian death keep that will give
you a four entry Jacobian so each one of
these is one of the equations derived
with respect to one of the variables you
can do that right but it requires fairly
complex mathematical knowledge like
knowing that the derivative of this sign
here is the cosine and knowing that the
this cosine doesn't matter for this
particular entry because it's in x2 and
here we derive by x1 so that's already
very challenging second you need to
evaluate the Jacobian at that point so
first you've done it symbolically and
now you actually need to put in the
numbers at the point you're interested
in which will give you this thing right
here which is a numerical matrix
whereas this was a symbolical matrix
then you need to calculate the
eigenvalues which is I mean you have
several methods of that you have several
methods of computing the largest
eigenvalue you could do power method you
could do decomposition there there are
numerous ways but none of these is like
particularly easy right and then lastly
you need to return the - max of the real
part which is the speed of convergence
of the system so not only do you need to
be able to tell whether it is stable
which is if this is negative you also
need to be able to say or if this is
negative you need to be able to say
whether it is locally stable or locally
unstable and since this is large is
larger than zero its locally stable and
this would be the decay rate zero point
four four one this is what you're asking
this model to output right now we'll
quickly go over the other things but not
as as in-depth but this is in control
theory where you're trying you have
almost the same thing you have a
differential equation but now in
addition to these variables you have
these control variables which you have
power over and you trying to decide can
I control this system with the
appropriate function and in order to do
that that's kind of the problem that we
had at the beginning I know it's not oh
yeah it is so what you need to do is
again differentiate the system with
respect to its internal variables
differentiate the system with respect to
its control variables evaluate a and B
calculate the controllability matrix
with the with one of the functions above
calculate the rank and optionally
evaluate this equation number three that
we saw before now the last task is
equally complicated it relates to the
stability of partial differential
equations using the Fourier transform
and again to
this it is a five step intricate process
where that is mix of symbolic complex
manipulation and numerical evaluation of
that symbolic things and here you need
to simply output two bits the one bit
says whether there exists a solution and
the other bit says whether it vanishes
at T to infinity so what are they
expecting here what they're doing is
they're gonna build a dataset that is
composed of these things and I think
they do it one by one so they take one
of the tasks and they're going to build
a giant data set of these things since
they all have solutions right you can
build a data set with labels because you
can actually build a you can build
software that does these steps because
you program mathematical knowledge into
the software but it's custom-made for
that particular problem in there simply
trying to in there they're not trying to
beat that program they're simply trying
to investigate can a language model that
knows nothing of math do this simply by
learning from data so they're going to
try to build the data set or they are
building data set and they do it in the
same way as this previous paper which
say we generate random functions by
sampling unary binary trees and randomly
selecting operators variables and
integers for their internal nodes and
leaves so they use any combination of
plus minus times divide X blog and so on
so all these functions can appear in
these things and they basically they
build a tree where they say okay we go
from plus and then here is five and then
here maybe it's minus sin of X and here
over is X of Y so that would be five
plus sine of X minus X of Y so they
build trees like this by randomly
sampling and then they simply feed this
to their mathematical program
to obtain a solution why and then they
feed all of this into that's now a
training data point this here is X and
here you have Y and they generate a
giant bunch of these things and they
feed them into the into the model they
say here is seek to seek models not even
sure what kind of models they use I
think they just they use transformers as
well so they they use standard
transformers I believe so yes
in all experiment we use the transformer
architecture with 8 attention heads we
turn our models with the atom optimizer
learning rate blah blah blah we vary the
dimension and the number of layers so
that's going to be interesting to see
how the size of this language model
influences how well this model can solve
these things so as you can see here they
build these data sets for local
stability they include systems with two
to six equations which is already fairly
fairly complicated and it would take a
human quite a while to to do this they
say we generate a data set with over 50
million systems so it's a pretty dense
sampling of this space and I feel this
is one of the important components here
they do make sure that none of their
tests so they do a trained test split
and they do make sure that none of their
test examples in the training data set
though they claim that they never
actually have to remove anything they
just check and the search space the
space of these trees here is so large
that it never happens that the that a
test sample or almost never happens that
a test sample is in the training data
set all right so they generate these
things and here are the results so for a
local stability it is trained to predict
this lambda that we saw at the beginning
the largest part of the eigen value of
the Jacobian corresponding to the
convergence speed of equilibria we
consider that predictions are correct
when they fall within 10% of the ground
truth and here you can see that their
best model achieves 96% if the degree of
if it's two equations so if the degree
of the system is two it achieves in 96%
accuracy so in 96% of the time the
convergence speed is within 10% of the
true conversion speed that's fairly
crazy right that's pretty good and here
the exact prediction of local
convergence speak to given precision so
how how many digits actually match of
that conversion speed so it's not only
10% off they also measure how many
digits match and here you can see that
as you up the degree of equation sorry
here the performance drops off as you
can see less and less and less and also
as you lower the number of layers in
your model or lower the dimensionality
the performance drops quite
significantly so that means the language
model sort of is doing real work here
and here you also see that if its degree
2 the convergence speed has pretty even
goes to two three or four digits often
but as you now increase the degree this
accuracy drops off fairly quickly
alright let's keep that in mind
so the surprising thing is that it
actually works and it works in
surprisingly big amount of the time now
I don't know you could bicker about this
10% and how bad or how easy this is and
so on but it is fairly it is fairly
complicated problem and to be within 10%
of the solution it seems quite
remarkable and the same things here
happen with the other tasks so here they
say they predict controllability in the
autonomous case so in the control theory
they predict these two things whether
it's controllable
and then they output this K matrix that
we saw before
yeah so here you can see that if they
have high enough dimensions and high
enough layers with sample systems with
three to six equations they achieve
again a 97% in the prediction of whether
the system is controllable or not now
remember this is a binary prediction but
still it requires a it requires a good
understanding of math for a human to
solve this again we see this drop off
with dimension and layers but you know
the is just this number here is pretty
good compared to the 50% you'd have four
you get from pair to the 50% you'd have
from random guessing also interesting is
when they look at is this correct this
correct sorry is the feedback matrix
correct so this matrix that you
optionally have to output they find that
if they analyze whether or not that's
within 10% of the true one they see that
pretty pretty quickly these accuracy
drops when they up the degree of course
the matrix as I understand it has more
entries at degree six than at degree
three so maybe that's understandable but
it drops off pretty quickly but what is
true is whether they call this correct
feedback matrix so from the feedback
matrix from the entries in that you can
read out whether it's the system is
controllable or not if all of the
eigenvalues I believe are negative or
positive or all the values are negative
or positive so basically by saying
whether or not these things are positive
or negative you can read out a
controllability and if they check
whether that property holds then that is
is fairly well so they argue here that
this shows that it doesn't
it doesn't predict the the matrix they
want but the matrix that it predicts has
the appropriate properties to solve this
other task right here
okay that's experiment to experiment
three as you can imagine is quite
different
sorry quite similar in that they
investigate these partial differential
equations and the Fourier transform the
model is given differential operator and
an initial condition is trying to
predict if a solution exists and if so
whether it converges to zero when T goes
to infinity the space the dimensions
between 2 & 6 so the random guessing
here would be I guess 25% because it's 2
bits you need to output and this model
performs extremely well even up to this
dimension 6 there is a drop-off with
dimension but it still does perform very
very well now they go into the
discussion a bit and they and this this
is the part that in this paper interests
me like how do you interpret these
results apparently you give these
mathematical things to a language model
that has no clue of math and just by
looking at examples it learns to produce
correct solutions and if you want to
teach that to a human the human would
have to go through all these steps right
so something is happening here and we'll
want to find out what and the discussion
is maybe they try to explain a bit why
they think this happens they say we
studied five problems of advanced
mathematics from widely researched do
you know and three of them we predict
qualitative and theoretical features
into we perform numerical computations
according to mathematical theory solving
these problems requires a combination of
advanced techniques symbolic and
numerical that seem unlikely to be learn
about from examples yet our model
achieves more than 95% accuracy on all
qualitative tasks and between 65 and 85
on numerical computations such high
performance
is over difficult mathematical tasks may
come as a surprise one way to generate
data set of problems with their
solutions consists in sampling the
solution first and deriving an
Associated problem for instance pairs of
functions with their integrals can be
generated by sampling and
differentiating from random functions so
here they hedge against theirs there's
this criticism and this was mainly a
criticism of their other paper which
they already addressed in their other
paper was if you want to find that if
you want to create a data set where you
have the function and then the label is
the integral of the function then there
is no common solution to draw to to
derive these integrals the derive is a
there is no common solution to integrate
functions I mean you can do it
numerically but there is no common
symbolic solution to integrate any
function and that's why what you can do
if you want to produce a data set is you
start with the integral already and then
you differentiate that to get to get a
thing and then you know that if you
integrate this you should get back your
original function but this biases the
data set because the sampling is now not
over these functions but the sampling is
over these functions and that might lead
to this distribution here being biased
so they hedge against that which I don't
care because it clearly in this paper
and they say in this paper data sets for
all considered tasks are generated using
a forward approach by directly sampling
as a result potential bias caused by
backward generative model do not apply
here and they studied problems from 3d
hedge against this argument that they
could have a biased data set which I
don't think anyone reading this paper
would leverage against them yeah so in
so here they basically say how good they
are how surprising this is all of this
requires math this part is irrelevant
because it hedges against an argument
that I don't think is reason the
against the paper and then the last
thing in their discussion is an
objection traditionally raised is that
the model might memorize a very large
number of cases and interpolate between
them which I think we know in language
model happens often right oh by the way
have I shown you how they encode this
into the language model I have not this
is the I guess this is the craziest part
they don't even put the numbers there
wait wait they don't even put the
numbers there they actually put the as I
understand it they put the string tokens
here right so they put these string
tokens of the math and then even like
composed so the number 142 they would
put as now there's an integer and then
the token 1 the token 4 and the token -
okay
and and the decimal point representation
is the sequence float 3.14 e in negative
1 so this is it's really just a string
there is no like the model would even
have to learn the decimal representation
of numbers to get that this 4 here is
actually not not just a different token
than 2 but it's 20 times larger because
it is in the position 1 in front of to
it so it's not 2 times larger like 4 is
to 2 but because 4 is you know one digit
away from two it's 20 times larger and
then this here is actually 50 times
larger than this so it seems like a
quite inconvenient way to input data
into the model and yet the model is
super accurate right and we already know
that these language models what they
tend to do is they tend to memorize the
training date or abstracted in a way
that they can sort of interpolate
between fuzzy versions of the training
data they here they say this is unlikely
sorry this is unlikely because first
because the size of our problem space is
too large to be memorized so say for all
consider problems we did not get a
single duplicate
over 50 million generated examples
second because in some of our problems
such as non autonomous control even a
model with a one-layer in 64 dimensions
obtains a high accuracy and such a small
model would never be able to memorize
that many examples which is true right
this is um this is a fair defense
against your just interpolating training
data but I think the kind of broader the
broader scope of this criticism would be
something like your model is just kind
of learning the pattern regularities of
the textual data that you feed in it's
not actually learning math it's just
learning sort of okay there is like a
cosine and if there's a cosine here
followed by an exponential function that
often leads to like a very low number of
this lambda right and then if a very
similar thing comes it comes across a
very similar thing in the test sample
even though it's not exactly the same
thing it will map it to like a similar
place in the label space I mean this is
literally machine learning this is
literally regression but I think the
more the broader scope of this criticism
is that what your model might be doing
might simply be sort of a very simple
regression on these tokens or on the
these context-dependent tokens rather
than this internal mathematical
reasoning and I don't well it is true
that it's probably not memorizing any
examples this still doesn't and while it
is also true that they did not get a
single exact duplicate what it would be
interesting to know is how many like
approximate duplicate so can you
basically solve the problem with a
nearest neighbor approach that would be
my my question can you solve the problem
with a nearest neighbor approach over
there training data set because that
means you basically don't need the
mathematical knowledge they say third
because for some of our problems
we know from mathematical theory that
solutions AG the real value of
eigenvalues cannot be obtained by simple
interpolation and I mean that is also a
valid defense but I think the argument
goes further than just simple
interpolation it what we mean by
interpolation is not we interpolate the
real values of the eigen values what we
mean by interpolation is sort of
interpolation in the regression space of
these tokens like we know that if we go
from a sign to a cosign maybe the the
the sign of the output flips at the end
and that's what we mean by interpolation
like when we see two equations that are
very similar like x squared plus 4x
minus the sine of X and then we see x
squared plus 5x minus twice the sine of
X what we mean by interpolation is that
we now get a test example that says x
squared plus let's say 4x minus 3 times
the sine of X then what we would
interpolate is sort of these these
things or yeah I'm making a bad example
right here maybe I should go with X x
squared and this is third I know these
things aren't exactly equal but this in
the middle would be sort of an
interpolation in in token space and if
you train the language model it will
recognize that maybe I can interpolate
whenever the coefficient here is just
different or I can interpolate when
there's just you know if there's like a
log X here that doesn't really change
anything so I can interpolate between
the two but I might not be able to
interpolate when the exponent here is
different so if you give a training data
set you teach the model where it can
interpolate and where it can't now again
it's not able to remember the training
data but it will be able to sort of
abstract it and then
it was early and abstract the patterns
from it which is good right that's
machine learning but there's no evidence
here that this does any mathematical
reasoning so up until now all that has
built up is sort of if you read the
abstract can advanced mathematical
computations be learned from examples
neural networks can learn advanced
theorems complex computation without
built in mathematical knowledge all of
the story here all of this this showing
of hey look at what all what steps is
required to solve these problems and
even this discussion here basically says
hey you need mathematical complex
reasoning to arrive at the solutions and
then in the conclusion in the conclusion
they say it seems that our models have
learned to solve these problems but that
does not mean they learn these
techniques we used to compute their
solutions problems such as non
autonomous control involve long and
complex chain of computations yet even
small models so means one layer
transformers with 64 dimensions achieve
high accuracy most probably our models
learn shortcuts that allowed them to
solve specific problems without having
to learn or understand their theoretical
background such a situation is common in
everyday life yada-yada-yada
so here in this in this paragraph here
they sort of counter their whole
narrative of the paper and that's I
guess that's sort of - it's fair right
they criticize their own work which is
good for research it's also to hedge
against criticism and it's to be a bit
real this it's a it's a good paper right
because it's a nice and interesting
story and then at the end you also say
look this might actually not be all that
what it's made up or what it seems like
to be and I I agree with this statement
right here it's that probably the model
learns short cuts and the short cuts
might be just in a way of
pattern matching the of pattern matching
of whatever patterns you extract from
the training data you pattern match that
and you relatively simply interpolate
between those matched patterns not
between the training data itself but
between the match patterns and therefore
you can arrive at approximately good
solution so what I would have liked to
see from such a paper right they say
that we leave that to future research
after making really kind of big claims
in the introduction and the abstract
they have taken three different problems
here right there's this locus some local
stability then there is this this
control theory and then there is this
stability of three different problems
and okay they try to show that they can
apply this to a diverse range but what I
would have expected from a paper like
this is they even they even smell out
here are four things that you need to do
to solve this if we were to teach this
to a human right now if you have trained
the model and you evaluated it it is
really good at this task for which you
thought you need you know to do these
four steps what would be really
interesting is to now introspect your
model and see can can I somehow show
that my model lore has in somewhere in
the intermediate layers has this
quantity right here and it's not just a
nearest neighboring in some learned
pattern space that would be an actually
interesting research question right so
rather in my mind rather than having
three different things where they all
you know they demonstrate the same thing
over and over and over again that this
actually works it would be a much more
interesting question to introspect the
model and parse out ken cannot for
example you can see can i reconstruct
this quantity from the inside of the
model when the model isn't specifically
trained to give me back this quantity
because I know this quantity would be a
step on these on the path of the
solution right if I want to get the
solution I almost have to
calculate this quantity can I parse this
out from the middle of the model
somewhere when the model isn't
explicitly trained to give me this if I
can then I can really make the point
that the model does something like this
and learn something like this from data
whereas if I can't that would be more of
an evidence that the model is simply
sort of pattern matching close enough
seen examples in the training data right
so that's a bit of my of my criticism
right here is that they they show it
works which is pretty cool but then they
they don't do the sort of interesting
experiments of these of this
introspection right here which is a bit
sad but you know they leave it for
future research which I guess is gonna
be themselves and that's how you make
two papers so no I don't want to be too
critical it's a very cool paper and I
invite you to check it out and leave a
like and subscribe and leave a comment
of what you think of this kind of
research of this paper and whether or
not you think I'm totally wrong that's
entirely possible
okay I'll see you next time bye bye